jeff snyder here for collider and i'm
sitting down with the team behind no man
of god
a new movie about ted bundy playing the
tribeca film festival i'm joined
by elijah wood luke kirby and director
amber seeley thank you for joining me
thank you for having me thank you when
we're talking about festival films
there's no trailers out yet people
aren't really sure what what these
movies are about so amber why don't you
sort of explain
uh you know what no man of god is really
all about
i'm going to pass that to elijah oh my
god
amber um
oh well that's set up now the pressure's
on um
no man of god is a film that depicts the
last four years of ted bundy's life
uh as he sat on death row awaiting
execution
and it it uh it depicts his relationship
with fbi profiler bill hagmeyer
that met him on a number of occasions
leading up to his execution
and it's about what sort of transpires
between those two men um
you know bill was uh
it was early days in the fbi profiling
so he took the sort of
that opportunity when nobody else really
wanted to because ted was so
manipulative and really was very
distrustful of of
the fbi and law enforcement in general
and what transpired was
a an actual connection you know at the
end of it
ted considered bill his best friend bill
did not consider ted his best friend
um but you know in addition to helping
families get clarity on on you know the
the whereabouts of
of their of their family members um
there was
also uh you know a human connection
between these two people
um it's a fascinating story that
is not about glorifying ted bundy but
rather getting into the heart of
who he was as a as a flawed and deeply
troubled individual
i think that was a great answer it is
all about finding closure for
for those victims um so how did you find
your way to this project
wouldn't it be funny if i passed this to
luke
i uh clearly i'm getting it's i'm
getting hungry
um it was it this project came in the
way that i think things are supposed to
happen it came to my manager
i think she just had a relationship with
spectra vision and made them a bit and
it came to her and
i don't even know if they talked about
me before that but anyway she sent me
the script
and i read it and then my first thought
was like another bundy movie what the
hell
and then i read it and it's such a great
read and and i immediately had a take on
it and
i obviously you know have been a fan of
elijah's
for forever and loved spectrovision and
so i was like
yeah i'll go and i'll pitch my take and
if they like it great and if they don't
no worries but i said to them
as like a parting thought i was like
look you don't have to hire me but you
need to hire a female director like you
can't make a movie about two men sitting
in a room talking about raping and
murdering women
and not you know in today's you know
climate uh not have a female director
and they were like oh no we're way ahead
of you we know that already and
um yeah so we just connect connected and
they liked
my take and uh and it was off to the
races
and luke as amber noted we have seen a
lot of ted bundys
on film especially lately but i thought
you were really terrific
i loved how you know what you brought to
that role so how did you approach
playing ted
did you look at other performances to
sort of differentiate your own that kind
of thing
it didn't look at other performances i
approached it
uh with you know great hesitation and
you know reluctance and
uh fear uh
but um i kind of entrusted amber to sort
of take us on a
on a bit of a ride that was
um you know not going to be
uh you know for all of the kind of
ghoulish reasons that one can
endeavor to tell the story um
you know there is a a kind of a glut of
research available and i you know i
um took as much of it in as i
could stomach you know depending on the
day
and i think all of it was probably very
very valuable i
i i do think probably the richest
resource that we all had
was you know um bill hagmar being
being available over the phone um
he is a you know exceptional resource
he's also
you know just a uh
something about him uh gave
the threat of it all humanity and
made my um hesitation
uh sort of just dissipate
quite quickly um because you know his
his experience is real truthful
and he's you know he's the real deal so
uh that to me i i think was probably the
best
uh gift that we had that was going to be
my next question for you elijah in all
these books that i i've read hagmeyer
is often like a supporting character so
it's kind of really cool to see him
as a lead you know what were your
discussions like with him
you know leading up to production and
what do you think makes him such a good
profiler
well look you know if circumstances were
different we would have spent a lot
of time with him so i only regret that
we made the film during a pandemic for
that specific reason
um we had you know plans to travel east
and sit down with him and
engage in a lot of conversation um that
being said
you know definitely spoke to him and
um you know i think it was important for
me
uh you know i certainly felt the
responsibility of bringing him to life
in an honest and truthful way that felt
accurate and true to his
experience um and yes you're right
to he is not a star performer
uh in in the history books that pertains
to the to the life of ted and that's
actually for a reason
it's because he's not he doesn't have an
agenda he didn't make a book
uh he didn't grant a lot of interviews
to discuss his relationship with ted
he really he's a man of integrity um he
was there to
to fulfill a specific purpose largely
to bring closure to families and to try
and tie up those cases and as best he
could
um wilst also trying to understand the
psychology of ted
so it's it's his humanity and his his
integrity that is
that that you know is a through line of
that particular story and is true of his
entire career
and when you speak to him that becomes
so apparent as well
um i don't know if that's totally
answered your question but i think you
know
there's a there's a very good reason why
he's not he's a side character
in the the grander stories of ted
because
he he um he wasn't he's not a loud
personality
he's a he's a he's gentle uh he's
intelligent he's considered
he's in he's human um he doesn't
approach
you know what he does which isn't to say
that that the others
are bad at their jobs they're great at
their jobs it's a very different
approach and i think
what's sort of lovely about him is he's
unassuming
very humble and it's that quality
actually that i that allowed him
to be uniquely innately
uh perfect for for that relationship
with ted
ted was so distrustful um of law
enforcement and ted wanted to be the
smartest guy in the room as well that
was a big part of it
um but but bill is disarming
in in who he is and that allowed for
that connection to even be possible
um as great as your your two leads are
in this film amber
the scene that that kind of has haunted
me is when you stay on that production
assistant that female production
assistant
and you're forced to watch her listen to
ted recount his crimes
can you sort of talk to me about that
scene and what were you are hoping to uh
you know
communicate to the audience with it well
in a sense that's almost like that and
then also
in the under the water monologue that
you know it goes sort of meta those are
the two moments that i think encapsulate
the best like what i was trying to say
you know
why i was directing this movie you know
i mean
put it putting it really bluntly like
watching her have to have to sit and
listen to these two men
you know talk about these horrendous
crimes is sort of like what i felt
as a human being you know being like
watching our society and
i include myself in that be so
fascinated and interested in people like
bundy so it was kind of like
that's the most me moment i guess in the
movie those those two moments
um but i just yeah i just i love that
i don't know i don't i don't i don't
know i just had that idea and i was like
i
i love that like you know the natural
choice would be to stay on bundy you
know
and and i just thought like what's it
like for the women in the room
you know what's it like for the 24 year
old assistant
you know and i don't know people will
recognize it but all the women in the
film are dressed like
victims actual bundy victims and so to
me it was also
a commentary or a way to um to bring
them into the story because i felt like
it was offensive to make a movie with
bundy as such a big character in it and
not
have the victims be present in some way
that was meaningful
and um you know not kind of
cheesy or melodramatic you know and i
didn't want to do the typical like
listing of their names at the end of the
movie but
but i wanted them to be present and have
weight and uh
and so you know that the women i don't
know if you noticed but throughout the
film like the women
you know first they're just clocking
bill and looking bail at bill and
the clocking bundy and then they look
directly at us and they're asking us
essentially why are you so fascinated
with this guy
why do you remember his name and not my
name you know
since this movie is mostly two guys in a
room
talking uh what were there any movies
that you looked uh
to as influences you know as far as how
you were gonna stage and shoot this
thing
uh my dinner with andre i mean
there were a ton but honestly i it was
mostly
i like to do a lot of visual research in
the beginning and then at a certain
point i have to sort of shut
the door to other filmmakers because
i'll suffer from
just too much fear and anxiety and
imposter syndrome and like i'll never be
as good as them you know so i try not to
borrow or mimic uh too much from the
filmmakers that i admire but i certainly
do when i'm coming up with
the look of the film and the tone of the
film i do a lot of research on other
movies but
but then it's really just i come at it
from an emotional place you know i used
to be an actor and so i come at it from
a place of like
who are these people what are they
feeling what are their objectives like
what are they trying to get the other
person to feel
um and that's kind of like my way in and
then the camera work is an extension of
that and the production design is an
extension of that of like the emotional
state
to me it's always grounded in some sort
of reality even if it's a meta moment or
a
you know a dream moment i like it to be
grounded in performance you know i mean
i think people will watch
any good performance no matter what the
story is no matter what the production
design is if the performances are
riveting
i'll watch it if the performance is bad
it doesn't matter how good the story is
or how good
it looks i'm i'm not i'm not involved so
to me the most important thing is the
performance and i just really lucked out
having these two rock stars you know
uh who can do anything i threw out them
so
it's really fun and luca is is it tough
not to judge
uh such a despicable character like
bundy when you're playing him because
you do have to sort of
present what little humanity there is
there
yes it it is uh hard definitely hard not
to
uh judge uh
it's still hard um
you know i i don't have
a lot of interest in sort of
participating in a conversation that
sort of
tries to um give his motivations any
purchase
or reason you know um
but you know uh
you just have to dive in i do you know i
i do do have an exercise of kind of
imagining
people as children you know
uh and and that seems to be a kind of a
good way into
embracing even the worst uh of us
um so you know in that regard
you know i that was the the best i could
do
to kind of find an in
an in with him if there was any at all
uh you know
but yeah i'm no i'm no angel i'd throw a
stone
probably a few or a brick or like a
you know [ __ ] chainsaw you know i get
it
sure um uh well i i did want to just you
know
close i guess on this note with you
elijah it seems like we're seeing you
on camera acting every couple of years
would you say that your
primary passion right now is producing
um i don't know that one holds uh
sway over the other necessarily um the
producing is ever present
you know the word just the nature of it
we're always developing something or
you know on in post on something it
occupies a majority of my time but
it's yeah that's not it's not that one
takes precedence over the other
um it's really just more circumstantial
um
you know in terms of that of the spacing
of those things as it pertains to the
acting
um you know i i i just love the
filmmaking process so in in whatever way
i can be a part of something and
facilitate i just like to to do that you
know
cool well i've been watching you since
the days of the good sun so uh
keep up the good work oh yeah yeah i
love it we're talking about crazy serial
killer movies right yeah yeah yeah
oh thanks jeff that's nice i think one
of my one of my favorites so
everybody check out no man of god at the
tribeca film festival elijah luke and
amber thank you so much for joining me
awesome thank you